tonight i mean how excited are you i am
more than excited the diversity and like
the final five is giving me like anxiety
is it mike is it marianne is it romeo
that's who i want i want romeo okay i
was like who who has impressed you the
most this season i would definitely have
to say marianne the way marianne has
handled her advantages and playing
low-key but also playing last episode so
aggressively i am here
i stand marianne
how are we doing
what's up guys
we're we're praying for marianne
okay well that was i was gonna say i was
like if she wins that will be two
canadians back to back i mean what do
you think it is about us canadians it's
just i think the canadians are amazing
but also if marianne wins it would be
the first african-american black female
in 20 years historic yeah that would be
great um i think if marianne wins
back-to-back with erica we might have to
talk to props and reconsider this whole
canadian policy because they might be
too good i just like to say i'm from
canada okay call bryce back jeff you
heard it first i'm from canada
i love that um that so obviously you
guys the soul survivor alliance i mean
you have to look at what you guys have
been able to accomplish and just feel so
much pride i mean what does it mean to
you to just see especially the season
has just been so it has a diverse cast
and it's also so entertaining
for me my mom always told me leave
something better than you found it and i
spoke up and used my voice and i was
able to have a friend wendell who won
season 36 and like i always say a
participant in season 40 but to have my
support and to really like bring
awareness to an issue that
matters and i think that like when we
see season 41 in season 42 diversity
truly matters
yeah i'll say i agree with you as far as
leave something better than you found it
i'm always someone that i don't care how
well i did if people after me aren't
doing that that great or better than
what did i really accomplish in this
case we a lot of us and it wasn't just
us it was a whole group of us we stuck
our necks out we didn't know what the
consequences might be but we said you
know what
it now is the time we're going to speak
out and just try to make it a little
better we've seen it in season 41 we've
seen it with this season these casts are
dynamic we're seeing like
it's we're hearing better storytelling
i just think all around is great and i
think going into the future we're going
to see just this beautiful diverse array
of winners yes and i'm here for it and
listen i love it i think the game play
is a thousand times better and i love
the game of survivor and the fact that
they are incorporating 50 percent bypoc
not just in front of the camera but
behind the camera for me i live for it
um you know and obviously
what would you guys like to see
because you know change is still needed
to be made what would you like to see
going forward not just on survivor but
cbs reality shows in general can i just
answer this i would love to see more
black trans women representation i'm an
ally to that and that's what i stand for
as the first openly gay black man to be
on survivor i have to use my platform to
say that we need more black trans women
representation and that's what i would
love to see more in reality tv
i agree wholeheartedly bryce has opened
my eyes to just
so many things i've learned so much just
being best friends with this man
and
i agree
we have lgbtq representation but
regarding black trans people i think we
can do a better job
lastly i feel like i have to ask just
for the fans could you guys ever see
yourselves going back on survivor well
let me get them out the way i'm ready my
bags are packed yeah
this will be a third time for me i will
gladly go out there a third time bret
jeff you got my number call your boy